[Music]
on this friday night the cascading
effect of sex abuse allegations rattling
the nhl
one coach quits while the last man
standing is cleared by the league what
they do going ahead will be the real
test and the poisonous culture that's
pervasive throughout pro sports
updated recommendations about
vaccinations vaccine effectiveness
against infection may decrease over time
in some situations who else should get
another shot in the arm breaking news
ottawa's decision to appeal compensation
for indigenous children
and grateful for a miracle say thank you
for everything a covid survivor returns
to the hospital that saved his life
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
more fallout today from the scandal
involving allegations of sexual assault
that's rocked the national hockey league
the nhl says it will not discipline
winnipeg jets general manager kevin
cheval dayoff a one-time chicago
blackhawks executive over that team's
handling of accusations against a former
video coach in 2010. late last night
florida panthers coach joel quinnville
resigned over the case now both were
with the blackhawks when player kyle
beach reported that he was sexually
assaulted allegations he claims were
ignored mike trelay explains in our top
story tonight
connor de smith from up high overlooking
the ice there's no question who's in
charge of the jets eleven years ago
kevin cheval dayoff had far less power
as an assistant general manager for the
chicago blackhawks
that saved him in his current job as nhl
commissioner gary bettman decided he
cannot assign to him responsibility for
chicago's actions or inactions
a month before the blackhawks won the
2010 stanley cup aspiring nhler kyle
beach reported to the team that he had
been sexually assaulted by video
coordinator brad aldrich an explosive
report released this week found that
senior management decided it was more
important to focus on hockey and
ultimately allowed aldrich to resign a
month later to avoid an investigation
the story has sent shock waves through
the hockey world enraging former players
who are once victims of predators
what goes through my mind is that
we just don't get it like we just don't
get it chicago's inaction as well as its
letter of recommendation led aldrich to
a job with his hometown high school
where he was convicted of assaulting a
teenager for which beech feels partially
responsible
my message to him was that i'm sorry
because i feel like
maybe i could have done more than to
protect him beach's story has reignited
the conversation about the sometimes
toxic and homophobic culture in sports
in the background of that 2010 chicago
celebration a homophobic slight meant to
emasculate an opponent is clearly
written on the wall um this is all about
power and
who has the power and what they are
doing with it and why how to address
that overriding issue is the question
with many calling on the nhl to appoint
an independent body to field complaints
what they do going ahead will be the
real test of their sincerity and their
commitment to this nothing can erase
what happened but the hockey hall of
fame has agreed to do its part and look
at exiting out aldrich's name on the cup
mike drolite global news toronto turning
to the pandemic now canadian health
officials are expanding eligibility
guidelines for covet 19 booster shots
jamie morocco shows us who's on the list
now and now that pfizer has been
approved for use in five to 11 year olds
in the united states why parents here
still have to wait
ten months after her second vaccine
emergency room nurse nancy halupa can
now re-up on her covet-19 immunity with
a booster it would just be that added
insurance that
we have another layer of protection
frontline healthcare workers seniors
over 80 and adults in first nations
metis and inuit communities are strongly
recommended by canada's national
advisory committee on immunization nasi
to get their third coveted shot at least
six months after a second
senior 70-79 may also be offered
boosters as well as canadians who have
received two doses of astrazeneca or one
of the johnson and johnson vaccine
these vaccine recipients may be
susceptible to infections sooner viral
vector vaccines have been found to be
less effective than mrna shots which dr
teresa tam says are providing strong
sustained protection
for the general population there is
agreement that they don't need the
vaccine
in any
short immediate future
still provinces and territories seem to
be making their own plans when it comes
to boosters already bc yukon and the
northwest territories are offering third
shots to certain populations with
ontario to follow next week
meantime parents are left wondering when
they can expect first doses for kids
i'm excited for them
because they'll protect them especially
that they're in daycare and school
according to canadian health officials
pfizer's pediatric formula won't be
approved until mid to late november
i think it's important that we don't cut
any corners and we continue to trust the
the process a process that requires
patience one in place to protect even
the youngest of canadians jamie
marrocker global news toronto
the federal government is announcing
some exemptions and a grace period for
unvaccinated travelers in canada
starting tomorrow passengers aged 12 and
up are required to be fully vaccinated
to board domestic and international
flights trains and cruise ships
travelers who have not completed the
vaccination process can show proof of a
valid covet 19 molecular test until
november 29th
the transport minister says there will
be some exceptions including religious
or medical reasons and emergencies and
people in remote fly-in communities
accessing essential services will also
be exempt
breaking news now from ottawa the
liberal government is appealing a
federal court ruling over compensation
for first nations children the human
rights tribunal ordered the government
to pay each child removed from their
home and their parents or grandparents
40 thousand dollars which would leave
ottawa on the hook for billions but late
this afternoon the government also
announced that it will work with first
nations groups to come to an agreement
on compensation by december
canada chose to file a notice of appeal
today because we are concerned
about imposing a
one-size-fits-all approach
we've said this before
know that this is
that it is our steadfast goal to reach
an agreement outside the courtroom
today's decision is the latest in a
lengthy court battle raquel fletcher has
more from ottawa
in 2016 the canadian human rights
tribunal found ottawa discriminated
against first nations children by
knowingly underfunding child and family
services on reserve this led to as many
as 60 thousand kids being taken away
from their families and put in foster
care then on top of that
we had those inequalities and services
were resulting in denials of services
that not only harm children but in fact
have in legal orders been linked to the
deaths of some children on this much the
federal government agrees but it has not
accepted how to compensate residential
school survivors and their families
despite calls from indigenous leaders
and opposition parties and further we
are committed
to working with partners to end
this harmful system and to make sure the
kids at risk
get to stay in their communities where
we're at
is this will be the 21st time the
trudeau government has gone back to
court to try and overturn a court ruling
and they've lost every single time come
on justin look at look at the odds
you're not going to win this one do the
right thing by the kids angus says if
the government is really serious about
reconciliation it needs to give up this
legal battle and pay what it owes
indigenous children now raquel fletcher
global news ottawa and coming up a
little bit later we look at the role
indigenous education can play in
reconciliation and why some say there's
a need for a national curriculum but
first
the prime minister has wrapped up his
trip to the netherlands focusing on our
historic ties with the country but also
looking towards a cleaner greener future
michael couture is traveling with the pm
as trudeau gears up for back-to-back
summits focusing on climate change and
how to tackle it
a solemn ceremony marking a 76-year
friendship between two countries forged
by a war and nurtured by time
accompanied by canadian-born dutch
princess marguerite prime minister
justin trudeau laid a wreath in the
canadian war cemetery honoring the lives
lost when our country helped liberate
the netherlands in the second world war
it is an honor to address you today
in this historic hall
in the same room where winston churchill
called for a united europe in 1948
churro called for a united front in the
fight against extremism it's not just
conspiracy theorists and marginalized
angry people online
it's state actors too
using disinformation propaganda and
cyber warfare no trudeau didn't name
china in his speech but when answering a
question from a dutch parliamentarian he
said that country poses tremendous
challenges around the world to
democracies and our trading system
trudeau also urged unity against the
threat of climate change that you will
that canada will go for a much higher
ambition when it comes to climate change
in a q a session following the speech a
green party member asked trudeau about
going beyond the april promise to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by 40 to 45
percent by the year 2030. the prime
minister reiterated canada's commitment
to net zero emissions by 2050 adding our
country is a fossil fuel producing
nation we would not move forward on
announcing targets
where we didn't have a concrete and real
plan
to meet them reaching those targets is a
shared priority of trudeau and his dutch
counterpart part of the reason for their
meeting thursday was to prepare to rally
other g20 leaders to join in the climate
fight at this weekend summit in rome
there will be a lot of work being done
in rome tomorrow and on sunday and at
least the two of us will work very hard
to do whatever we can
to bring our colleagues along in the
g20. a task that could prove difficult
is some of the largest emitters of
greenhouse gas emissions that continue
to resist large-scale change will be
around that g20 table
chris
thank you mike
bc's premier is said to be in good
spirits as he recovers from a successful
surgery john horgan announced yesterday
that he'd be undergoing a biopsy after
doctors found a growth in his throat the
62 year old intends to keep working as
he receives treatment and has no plans
to step down the premier's office says
further updates will be issued in the
coming days
new details about a series of violent
attacks in winnipeg coming up what we're
learning about the victims
and the accused
plus the debris from a disastrous
container ship fire now littering a
pristine section of bc shoreline
more details are coming to light about
the victims in a string of violent
attacks in manitoba within hours
yesterday a winnipeg hospital supervisor
was viciously stabbed and two people
were found dead including a 73-year-old
woman in the rural community of new
bothwell joe scarpelli has more
it's a series of violent attacks that's
left people in manitoba shaken i'm
shocked
just to be frank judy swain was the
first victim found dead in her home
south of winnipeg early wednesday
afternoon now being remembered as a
hard-working farmer with a joy for life
who loved to dance she was just this
very bright light
i think probably most people who would
have interacted with her at a farmers
market or on her farm will be very
surprised to learn
that you know she was in her 70s
shocking too the reality that her son
was a suspect in her killing before
police could locate him there were
reports of a stabbing at seven oaks
hospital in winnipeg police say the
attacker there worked at the hospital
when he entered wednesday he stabbed a
colleague repeatedly she is candace
swarak the hospital says swarak was
speaking with a colleague when the
suspect walked through the doors passed
security and attacked her the hospital's
ceo says the chaos went on for minutes
in front of staff patients and their
families we had a number of staff that
jumped the individual managed to uh take
them off of the individual that was
being assaulted
um and uh and then hospital staff
reacted
immediately to care for uh their their
co-workers
swarek a long-time hospital worker in
her 60s was rushed for treatment and
remains in intensive care the suspect a
man in his 30s was arrested on site as
the investigation unfolded wednesday
police went to his father's home where
disturbingly he too was found dead
really nice man actually
but shocking to see that
there's tape around there to wake up in
the morning
the suspect remains in custody and has
not yet been charged as he undergoes a
medical assessment insight into his
motives and his mental health just some
of the questions still under
investigation
joe scarpelli global news winnipeg
disgraced fashion mogul peter nygaard
has made his first appearance in a
toronto courtroom the 80 year old
appeared by video conference from an
ontario jail cell
nygaard is facing several charges
including sexual assault the court heard
today the accusations involved seven
different women nygaard did not enter a
plea during the brief appearance he's
due back in court november 12 for a bail
hearing
and the obstruction of justice trial for
retired general jonathan vance has been
scheduled for may 2023 an ottawa court
made that decision today during a brief
video conference the charge against
vance stems from accusations he
repeatedly asked a woman to lie to
investigators who were looking into
allegations of sexual misconduct vance
retired shortly after that investigation
began
some new video to show you now of the
wreckage left behind by a shipping
mishap off the west coast of bc
containers from the mv zim kingston are
now washing up on the pristine shoreline
of northern vancouver island some
containers have broken apart littering
everything from fridges to toys to
clothing on the beaches 109 containers
fell from the vessel during a weekend
storm a fire on board that ship is now
out
just ahead a school in the forest part
of a movement to include indigenous
education in the curriculum
with the discovery of hundreds of
unmarked graves at former residential
school sites a national conversation is
underway into canada's treatment of
indigenous people part of that
conversation includes how we share the
indigenous experience and teachings with
students as alison bushnick reports some
say a commitment to education is the key
how many of you cut wood to stay warm in
the winter at glen allen elementary in
edmonton indigenous education is woven
into the fabric of the day we're here
today in the forest because this is our
university on this day elder wilson is
sharing traditions and appreciation of
the land
later he meets with school
administrators to review
programming this school is a model for
what indigenous education looks like
when developed in partnership with
indigenous leaders i tell my students
every day you know what what i'm
teaching you your parents are my age if
not a bit older so when they went to
school they didn't learn this because
all this history basically was erased
but without a national mandatory
curriculum these teachings and
experiences aren't required in all
schools education is the key to change
education is the only way to create real
long-term sustainable change even in the
past few years there were incidents of
public school students in different
parts of the country being asked to
describe the advantages or benefits of
residential schools there are still
definitely you know bias and racist
resources that are kicking around
they're not as easy to find which is a
good thing education professor pamela
toulouse has written more than 50
teaching resources she says it's a
matter of commitment if indigenous
content is not mandatory or else if it's
viewed as you know an elective then i
can guarantee that indigenous peoples
are also viewed at the same level do we
still have our languages
do we still have our cultures
back in edmonton teachers students and
indigenous leaders here are an example
of how education can drive change our
students are the ones who are going to
educate their parents their friends
other people in the community give
yourself a round of applause alison
buchnik global news
there's much more to that story and you
can watch the full report on the new
reality tomorrow night at seven right
here on global
[Applause]
next a heartfelt thank you for
life-saving help
the queen has now been told to rest for
at least the next two weeks the advice
comes from her doctors after she was
taken to the hospital for tests more
than a week ago the 95 year old can
still take on light duties including
some virtual audiences but traveling and
bigger events are out
doctors and nurses at an ontario icu
just experienced something they thought
might never be possible about 18 months
ago their first critical care covit 19
patient who some thought wouldn't
survive returned to the facility to
thank the front line healthcare workers
who helped save his life karen lieberman
brings us his story
it is a bittersweet day for mario
castillo he has returned to the
intensive care unit where he spent nine
weeks in the spring of 2020 attached to
a ventilator it was our first passion
with kobe that needed to be intubated i
did have an idea
this is going to be a long long-term
ventilation the recovery has also been
long and painful we sat down with him
when he arrived at st john's rehab it's
my
second chance castillo has since learned
to walk again and he's regaining the
feeling in his hands
no hundred percent but i start to
move
but before i stay like that
nope in my legs
i feel like numb
so much has changed since mario castillo
was a patient here in the icu in the
first wave at the time the medical team
wasn't certain he was going to make it i
remember how
worried we were for him
because we you know we didn't know that
much about the disease then we didn't
know what his outcome was going to be
castillo defied the odds and the former
patient is back with a heart filled with
gratitude say thank you for everything
to the front line health care workers
who saved his life
he's a miracle what almost actually took
my breath away to see him i had goof
bumps as program directors supporting
the critical care team cecile marvel
williams has been dealing with her own
loss i too lost my mom
to covet and to see him today walking
talking to be able to come back and give
back to us
by sharing his experience
just
made me feel very overwhelmed the road
back from covid 19 has been a difficult
one for castillo but with the support of
his care team the future is bright karen
lieberman global news
amazing recovery and that is global
national for this friday night i'm chris
galas tonight's your canada is the water
tower in wetaskiwin alberta built in
1909.
city says it's canada's oldest
functioning water tower we love seeing
your canada so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks very much for watching robin gill
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a great weekend and happy halloween
[Music]